now Hannah I know you're a Taylor Swift
fan I mean I might have written a
rhetorical analysis on her 1989 album
wow we have recently been talking to
some celebrities who are big bachelor
nation fans and the other little things
to say about you we pulled the bites
together let's take a look I do think
and it can stay home now now they're
just using these poor women it's like
now it's you know it's the same yeah
they're saved
she's showing up a proposal and she's
throwing a whole spanner in the wheel
yeah ooh Jennifer Aniston and Charlize
Theron do you think it's shady no look I
understand I just keep coming up
the four times in the window how many
times will we see you on this season of
The Bachelor some people do think that
you are gonna show up and Peter and you
might be engaged right now wild girls
you keep watching is that we have to
always say do you show up on this season
again I do not know yes but it's okay if
you can't tell us you got to be good but
you know I was dancing on Dancing with
the Stars but let people are like hey
Peter was only a flight away Peter also
told us that he might have gone down a
totally different road if you had asked
him out take a look at what Peter had to
say I would have said yes and I probably
would have been eventually would you in
Hannah be together right now I mean you
never know the world may never know now
you know it's it is what it is so what's
your reaction to that um yeah I mean I
think it would have been different if I
would have asked him out I think we had
a very candid conversation on the
episode of The Bachelor that I was on
and you know it just I have to just
believe that everything happened for a
reason the way that it has and just move
forward because yeah it's hard to watch
that and be like what could I have done
what should I have a dime you still have
any feelings for Peter right now I'm
always going to care for him deeply
that conversation between you two was a
lot
that was a lot and I one thing that I
think has bothered me is I never would
have just gone and just started spilling
my guts about how I felt about him I
truly wanted to be there do my job of
hosting and I just had a vulnerable
moment and I mean I pride myself
sometimes for being honest to a fault
but if I get asked questions about how I
feel I'm gonna I'm gonna say what's
really truthful because I think that
especially in that situation you deserve
honest answers when you're you know
putting your life on the line and trying
to figure out your relationship so it
was a very hard conversations and then
go back to learning a rumba he asked you
to join his season did you consider it I
don't I can understand the logistics of
it and I think I'm I'm much more of a
realist in that way of like you know I
wanted to do something for myself and
move forward and I wanted to do my very
best on Dancing with the Stars and I
didn't want to let that opportunity go
but of course there was obviously still
feelings there and it was hard but also
I don't know if I could move back in
with into that mansion yeah it's like a
mansion but I call it the peasant house
because you just you literally are just
a bunch of girls and two bathrooms and
it's hard yeah and I don't they deal
with all the girls not the most
luxurious it's not it's not uh well
Chris Harrison told me that there's a
possibility you could be the
Bachelorette again so would you do that
I don't know right now I'm just like
trying to seize the opportunities that I
have and feel very confident and the
things that I say yes to and also
confident in the things that I that I
know worried about me right now sounds
like it's not totally a No
I don't I don't know okay I think
everybody thinks that like there was it
was a lot hard and bad about it I mean
hello
did we see my ending but there is a look
I think there's a lot of good that comes
out of it too I will never like
completely bash The Bachelor franchise I
think it has had a lot of its success
and the people that are together very
happily together and so of course I want
that but it doesn't have to be as the
Bachelorette yeah you've done quite a
lot I'm glad you wore waterproof mascara
today because they didn't give you any
but it's just fun feeder season so you
are so busy now with Dancing with the
Stars with this unbelievable tour Radio
City Music Hall
it's my mom's dream come true it's going
to be incredible you're gonna kill it
though yeah won Dancing with the Stars
you're living in LA now how is it being
here full-time I feel like this is the
I've only really been here like this a
week of like actually living a normal
life of I don't know like having a couch
and my TV is still on the ground but I'm
trying to just make a home for myself
here because I don't know it's on TV a
lot of the time that since I've been
here so I'm exploring now figuring out
where my spots are gonna be so Bulls I
like it so far so you're calling LA home
city life is it true that you cut your
car broken into yeah I'm not an Alabama
anymore mmm yeah that was everybody
importunate everybody's not so sweet
here oh my gosh yes I went in to a store
for 10 minutes in like a nice area okay
so this person did they get your of like
ID and stuff they have Hannah Browns and
from I know I find my ID everybody makes
fun of me because I carry this phone
purse thing is but it works very
fashionable it's very fashionable and it
had my ID so they do not know my
identity okay good
have you been dating anyone in LA no
that was really like a very firm no I
had time
that's just not like what's happening
for me by the way a lot of pageant women
on Peters season is it true that you
know some of the women - I the pageant
like the pageant world is very small in
a way like you know of everyone in a way
well what do you think of the women you
know are they good for Peter I don't
know mouth shut on that way I am okay
like everybody being honest yeah well
here's the thing Peter gave his first
impression rose to a woman named Hannah
he gave his first one-on-one date to a
woman from Alabama he's seen her holding
on to some stuff from you Hannah
yeah Alabama Hannah can't get away from
it
[Music]